out of the latest from the war in
ukraine after days of aerial and ground
attacks russia is closer to capturing
one of the largest cities in the eastern
donbass region that is still under
ukrainian control the u.s has now agreed
to send high-tech rockets you're looking
at some of them on your screen now like
those rockets that ukraine has asked for
and our mts tayab is following ukraine's
efforts to continue to slow the russian
advance
as moscow unleashes what's being
described as a frenzied push russian
forces now control most of severo donets
raining down heavy artillery and
engaging in ruthless street battles
russian troops are trying to push out
the last ukrainian forces from the
largest city in the eastern luhans
province at least fifteen hundred people
have been killed and up to fifteen
thousand remain trapped here with few
safe places to shelter
this woman and her grandmother tell a
local journalist they remain in good
health when this explosion went off
close by
it's a horror repeated across the dawn
bass including in the nearby village of
sloviance where a russian airstrike
killed three and injured six
says elena voteenko
it happened right in front of us she
says
it's a nightmare
at a military hospital in zappos which
is to the west we were given access to
an operating room where trauma surgeons
remove shrapnel from a wounded soldier
his injuries aren't life-threatening but
the same can't be said for others who
are treated here says dr dimitro
malkovsky you also sometimes lose
patience too don't you
yes i do as people say every doctor has
own symmetry
their own cemetery yes
for those who make it the fighting
spirit lives on this soldier who goes by
the name mulfar is recuperating from a
shrapnel wound to the leg and says
despite having been on the front lines
for over three months he wants to rejoin
the fight
you sound very committed to
this war into winning this war
what i know is that unless we really put
an end to this war russia will only
continue and continue he says
war will not allow my country to develop
and war means i will never be able to
live a normal life
now for the new york times president
biden wrote in an essay that the only
way to end russia's invasion is through
direct diplomacy but even then the u.s
will continue to provide this country
with the weapons that it needs so that
when it's at the negotiating table it
has all the leverage it needs nate
mts in ukraine thank you